[music]
Good day ladies and gentlemen. This is
Aza and RZ Auto. Today I'll be working
on a 2010
BMW
535i.
Uh the owner has a working key which is
this. I needed this. As you can see the
car is on. So we are going to make a
strike key for him. Presently this is
the key I'm going to add to the system.
It's not problem yet. As you can see it
is not responding.
So we just turn off the system. Let us
automatic selection to detect the
V number for this car.
As you can see, 2010 L5
Europe spec
control unit
vehicle information.
So this is the vehicle information we
have. [sighs and gasps]
We're going to take a screen of that.
Let's confirm the frequency
868.
The coding operation
ignition on this backup coding.
Backup successful.
Um you create a folder.
So
backup is successful.
Go back.
[snorts] Add key operation. Add key
learning
via OBD.
Here
we have um two keys
the job.
So
let's read the SK values.
[snorts]
File downloads completed.
Backing up coding. Preparing for
programming.
Please don't touch any button.
So programming in process. Do not touch
any button on the vehicle.
Programming post-process
processing in process.
reading password. Password read
successfully.
I'll take I'll pause and take a
snapshot. So, password read
successfully.
Now we write key.
So you're going to press the new key
close to the ignition coil
as you can see.
And we press okay.
Click okay.
Okay. Learning
is divided into two steps.
So we are going to wait.
Okay. Rating successfully.
Place the key close to the start
induction coil and press the switch for
10 seconds.
Okay, please don't be.
So, it's placed on the induction coil.
I'm going to press the switch for 10
seconds.
has light up.
Please take this key out.
>> You can go out now.
>> Just hold it. It's
>> stay out with it. So we make you move
small commotic here.
>> Okay.
>> Just stay at that corner there.
>> So I've taken the old key out. This is
the new key.
>> Yeah.
>> So with the new key I've been able to
put the ignition on.
Now the car has started.
This is Aan RS Auto. Kindly like, share
and subscribe to my YouTube channel and
follow me on my Facebook page. So next I
will test the remote part.
Uh yeah.
Lock.
Unlock. [clears throat]
Unlock.
Start.
Place the proximity function. Here's the
key.
It starts the car. So, I'm going to turn
it off. I'm going to take this
um new one out and bring the old one.
The former key.
>> Hello. Bring bring the bring the other
key. Please let me give you this.
>> Bring this one.
>> So this is the former key
that we calling start the car.
lock
and unlock.
[snorts]
So this is Aan Auto. Kindly like, share
and subscribe to my YouTube channel and
follow me on my Facebook. Thank you.
Thank you for watching.
>> [music]